what happened to this skull cracking
people exploding extended fight scene in
The Flash apparently it was just a
little too R-rated for a PG-13 audience
The Flash was probably never intended to
push the PG-13 envelope the way that
some of the entries in the Snyder verse
did during an interview with collider
Kaye was asked to Dish about any
noteworthy deleted sequences from The
Flash The Silo scene was a lot longer I
did a lot of stunts for that scene and
some I think were a little too rated R
and they ended up kind of bringing it in
the scene in question sees Callies Kara
zorel being rescued from a remote
Russian prison while she is weak and her
powers are depleted when Barry Allen and
Company first find her once she's taken
outside and the sunlight hits her body
she regains her abilities and lays ways
to the guards at the facility Kaye
didn't go into detail about what
precisely made the deleted content too
over the top for the theatrical version
of The Flash but it can probably be
assumed that it was just too violent